our anniversary was right around the
corner and I was the one that made the
decision to go to Dos Palmas it's a
beautiful island resort but then they
told me the cost and it was too much and
it was on the tip of my tongue to say
look at a place in town but then I
thought oh we'll just treat ourselves
and that fateful decision is what
changed the course of the rest of my
life
I noticed that across the way there was
a couple there a Filipina and a guy that
had more of an American accent
we had a lovely meal that first night
then took a walk on the beach we talked
and talked and talked
I remember Martin saying this is an
anniversary that we will never forget
we woke from a sound sleep
there had been some talk about changing
rooms the night before and I thought oh
well maybe we've overstepped Martin
started to head for the door I said you
know what you need to get short fun we
didn't have clothes on
I did not know what to think
oh my heart was in my throat I said oh I
didn't know what to do he grabbed the
sheet wrap it around you I didn't have
anything on oh no I said I'm not dressed
so I grabbed the closest thing to me
the guy was shoving me in the back I
didn't like him telling me what to do
I just decided in my heart that I wasn't
gonna run slowing down was probably the
worst possible thing I could have done
in that moment I guess I'm lucky that I
didn't lose my life right then and there
I saw a waiting speed boat Martin was
already sitting in there boy was I glad
to see him he grabbed my hand and he
said are you okay
thoughts were whirling through our heads
who were these guys
pirates robbers what did they want with
us